yannick mireur politologue spécialiste
des états unis bonsoir yannick mireur
merci d'être avec nous on vient de voir
un to say that un teint manifestement
contre les journalistes américains en ce
moment que ce qu est il en train de se
passer
aux etats unis selon vous écouter dans
une certaine mesure on peut dire que
c'est un pays fait face de lui même
parce qu'il ya eu des engagements
historiques dans les années 70 aux etats
unis
donc ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui est
assez rare sur la question de la presse
que vous évoquez cela ne contienne
simplement réserve quand même des
commentaires que l'on pourrait faire que
il y à une exercice du pouvoir américain
assez loin des pratiques habituelles qui
tendrait plutôt à privilégier un
discours d'unité nationale
le res que les procédures positif tous
les protocoles politique et de soutenir
aussi la constitution des états unis
on voit bien qu'il ya les positions si
vous voyez la dérive du département de
la justice en particulier qui nous place
dans une situation assez particulière
qui éclaire évidemment l'élection
présidentielle à venir sur les questions
des mbs elle-même je pense élargir la
chose parce que la dimension purement
raciale malheureusement passe à côté
d'un certain nombre de choses aussi
révoltante qu'elle puisse l'être
elle s'inscrit dans une histoire et une
culture unit plus large où il ya trois
points clés le premier est celui de la
condition de la communauté noire aux
etats unis plus marginalisées
généralement plus représenter la
population carcérale plus représentés
aussi en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
une situation sociale plessis filiation
américaine y un autre sujet qui suit la
police et des règles d'engagement
d'appréhension ou d'arrestations des
forces de police n'étaient dîner une
littérature et y aurait abondance qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude dans d'autres pays
sur ces sujets une structure
institutions policières aussi fédéral
d'un côté et cuit basé sur les états de
l'eau sur ou le rappel 18 nine
département de police à travers le
territoire américain tous même des
pendant les années dorées enfin il ya
aussi l'amendement numéro 2 c'est à dire
la liberté du port d'armes créé une
situation quand même particulière à la
force
exercice il était de la police et puis
pour les manifestants ce qu'il se
confier confronte violemment comme c'est
le cas maintenant aux forces de l'ordre
on a parlé des tensions des violences
contre les journalistes on parle de ces
émeutes comme en explique cela
aujourd'hui évidemment la crise
sanitaire beaucoup pointent du doigt
également donald trump qui est accusé
pour beaucoup d' attiser justement ces
violences et ces tensions dans le pays
bon évidemment regretter certaines
maladresses et pour savoir qu'en
perspective de tout cela le vote noir ne
se portent pas naturellement sur
monsieur travaille habituellement comme
le boss de juifs aussi aux états unis
est très majoritairement à 30 85 %
tchiroma le parti démocrate que ce sera
probablement le cas de joe biden
continue de sa personnalité sur pour la
prochaine élection présidentielle
en revanche bon l'intensité de ce que
l'on voit est particulière gelé viens de
lire leur jeu prend cependant que la
bavure policière
qualifions pas de bavure à ce stade se
répétera et qu' il ya ici une
inflammation de la population blanche et
noire d'ailleurs devant de tels actes de
tels écarts policiers je vous rappelle
quand même que le officier de police en
question a déjà été réprimandé fait
l'objet déjà deux remarques à plusieurs
reprises dans sa carrière votre état
jugé très particulier mais qui si je
puis dire imprime une réalité sociale
beaucoup plus large
les huit ans barack obama n'ont pas
permis ne suffirait pas évidemment de
rétablir donne une réponse sociale et
économique à la communauté noire aux
etats-unis je pense que c'est sale
premier sujet a révoqué et les
manifestations
leur violence servat s'est mal au fond
cette cause elles ont plutôt tendance à
effaré et a joué le jeu en quelque sorte
ce faire le jeu ou l'électoral du point
une empreinte par exemple quand il a
consolidé la base électorale
majoritairement blanche est
majoritairement aussi le classes
populaires aujourd'hui clairement
yannick mireur ce sera ma dernière
question comment on s'en sort parce que
dans les années 60 il y avait de vrais
lits
heures qui était prêt à se mettre autour
d'une table martin luther king avait
devant sony y avait les kennedy
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu' on n'est pas
dans ce schéma là comment se sortir de
cette crise qui peut aller en de mal en
pis oui elle c'est assez difficile de
prévoir cette crise comme la crise
sanitaire dans une certaine mesure c'est
à dire qui était très affable soir comme
comme les incendiaires aussi ambiant les
propos qui sont parfois tenus d'un côté
comme de l'autre
exit la polarisation et une
confrontation difficile de prévoir ce
qui peut se passer
sinon appel à l'ordre et à au
manifestant à qui on je vous dirais
établie l'an lors l'argument si on peut
dire à revenir à une position plus
simple les élections les élections
présidentielles en devenant en quelques
mois les les conventions les
investitures et candidats démocrates
d'un côté républicain autre que peut-il
se passer aussi au sein du parti
républicain ont permis au président tél
ce serait un cas unique mais ce serait
avoir je pense que ce sera cela il va
définir les thématiques de la campagne
chine d'un côté et poussé le
gouvernement américain de monsieur train
de l'autre des questions de social est
ce que la crise économique ou d'ailleurs
l'ensemble de ces thématiques la
l'intérieur de ça la question
une fois de plus du port d'armes
surtout de règles d'engagement de la
police de la localité policière plus
accessible aux etats-unis peut-être
cahier à anneaux plus masquer les
attaques des forces de l'ordre par des
délinquants ça existe aussi quand même
aux états unis
je pense que c'est le débat public on
peut bien espérer mieux
à ce stade qui permettra de le traiter
le sujet je ne nie pas nécessairement de
l'améliorer mais ce sera la reine
démocratique avec une situation assez
nette entre probablement nos cieux trad
est certainement me by death de l'autre
côté qui sera la reine de deux débats de
confrontation pour le peuple américain
merci yannick mireur d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france pour nous
apporter votre analyse